y mi niña de 12 años
se desapareció
mileidy yadira santa ana laura piensa
muchas veces que lo vivido forma parte
de una pesadilla cuatro hijos un marido
y un hermano están desaparecidos otro
hijo de 11 años fue asesinado lo mataron
a él el 8 yo nos de la vida porque se
ensañó de esta manera conmigo si yo no
le hice mal a ninguno y si mi familia
hizo algo porque tuve que pagar yo
esto es duro y tal en algunos dos vivos
muy fortalecida
javits a dirige la comisión de búsqueda
de desaparecidos componente farc del
oriente de colombia y que vamos a luchar
incansablemente por encontrarlo ese es
nuestro lema
encontrarlos entonces este es para
muchos ex combatientes como laura el
único lugar al que pueden dirigirse para
reclamar a sus desaparecidos algo
imposible antes de los acuerdos de paz
de 2016 entre el gobierno y la guerrilla
de las farc porque yo nunca denuncie
nunca nada de ir a la deriva todo así de
miedo que porque de pronto me matan
bueno chavista lidera la búsqueda desde
este espacio de reincorporación de
firmantes de paz conocido como mariana
páez jr ubicado en mesetas meta han
documentado más de 800 casos que
permitieron a la unidad de búsqueda de
personas dadas por desaparecidas y el
comité internacional de la cruz roja a
ubicar a más de 100 desaparecidos
la comisión de la verdad cuenta más de
100.000 desapariciones forzadas por el
conflicto un crimen de lesa humanidad
los ex combatientes tratan de encontrar
a todas las víctimas del conflicto
los testimonios anónimos de excompañeros
una forma de reparación todos son
necesarios buscarlo porque su familia lo
está requiriendo su familia está
sufriendo la ausencia los los ha matado
en vida ya dichas tuvo 30 años en la
guerrilla donde llegó a ser comandante
todavía guardar recuerdos como su diario
escrito en la cárcel tras ser detenida
en un bombardeo donde perdió a su pareja
con la nueva independencia nuestra
patria liberar y sentar un precedente
por toda la eternidad y aritz a tiene un
hermano desaparecido después de toda una
vida armada en selvas como esta vuelve
ahora en su misión de búsqueda con una
nueva convicción el firme compromiso con
la paz